Oh async tasks how we have a love/hate
relationship with you on the one hand
you make it really easy to get work off
the main thread but on the other hand
you make it really easy to do a bunch of
really bad stuff my name is Colt McAnlis
and while async task provides some easy
interfaces if you're not careful it can
hurt your apps performance and end up
causing memory leaks so here's a
familiar situation the user wipes the
screen kicking off some bitmap decoding
to it occur and because that work is
going to take a long time you need to
hand it off to another thread so you
don't cause hitching in your animations
but once the bitmaps have been decoded
you need to get them back to the UI
thread so that you can update your views
if this happens a lot in your
application then it's not worth writing
all the one-off code snippets to make
this happen the right way this is
exactly why async task was created it
wraps up all of this gnarliness with
three simple function calls basically
the on pre execute function will happen
on the main thread and allow you to set
up the work you're about to do then the
do in background function will execute
on a worker thread actually doing the
computation and finally on post execute
is called on the main thread along with
the results of the work that you've just
completed simply overload these three
functions in your own class and async
task will do the rest
now while this seems like an ideal
solution you need to be cautious there's
some nuances with async tasks that can
get you into trouble firstly all async
tasks that are created will share the
same thread and thus will execute in a
serial fashion from a single message
queue so if you kick off 20 work orders
and the third one takes an hour the
other 17 will block and wait until it's
done this is especially dangerous if you
kick off some work that's got a long
running while loop in it basically it'll
just freeze that thread from doing any
future work now to be fair there is a
way to force async tasks to execute in
the thread pooled fashion but in reality
if you're venturing into that area you
might just want to use the thread pool
primitive directly instead of all that
madness anyhow the second big problem
might be a little bit more familiar how
do you actually cancel a block of work I
mean async task has this handy cancel
function but does that really do well
remember that threads don't directly
contain the ability to interrupt the
current code being executed if you want
a threaded block of work to be able to
terminate early
you have to do two things number one add
some logic to check for a flag that says
the work has been canceled and number
two once the block of work is finished
let the other functions know that this
packets results are invalid and this is
exactly what the cancel function in a
sync task does it will set a flag and
allow the is canceled function to return
true so your code can check that
regularly to see if it should exit early
in addition after do and background
returns a canceled async task will call
on canceled on the UI thread instead of
on post execute this is so you can
properly update your UI or destroy
specific memory allocations that you
might not need anymore
yada-yada-yada and finally be aware that
it's really really easy to leak memory
with async tasks
check out this very common seeing all
the time code pattern in Android apps
where an async task is declared as an
inner class of some activity this is a
really big problem having async tasks
declared is an inner class creates an
implicit reference to the outer activity
which can then result in lete memory
which means it won't be destroyed until
the async task work completes obviously
this is less than ideal if you're trying
to load a new activity and you still
have several destroyed activities in
memory since their work hasn't been
completed the gist here is that while
async task makes it really easy to move
work off the UI thread it's far from
being a silver bullet so don't be afraid
to check out some of the other threading
primitives in Android in case you need a
little different use case for example
handler threads are great when you need
a dedicated thread for callbacks to land
on thread pools work best when you've
got a mountain of small work objects to
do and intent services are really ideal
for background tasks or when you need to
get intent work off of the UI thread and
see that's the whole thing when it comes
to performance coding you have to
understand enough about the primitives
to know how they might help you and how
they might hurt you and if it's not
working move on to a better pattern
which is why you should check out the
rest of the Android performance patterns
videos and don't forget to ask your hard
threading questions in the Google+
community as well so keep calm profile
your code and always remember perf
matters